Some of the most memorable moments in recent
TV history weren't even planned, but were
instead born from inspired, improvised moments
between gifted actors.
They may have felt too perfectly placed to
be off-the-cuff, but here are a few genuinely
unscripted exchanges that took viewers — and
producers — totally by surprise.
And we're not making this one up on the spot:
there are definite spoilers ahead.
Stormborn smooch
Game of Thrones is a very expensive, obsessively
examined show, so it makes sense to assume
every moment must be scripted to the letter.
However, as it turns out, there's some room
for flexibility on the series.
In the season 7 episode "Stormborn," Yara
Greyjoy and Ellaria Sand get to know each
other a little better — before being interrupted
by an attack …
"Seems like you don't need a protector."
Actress Gemma Whelan, who plays Yara, revealed
after the episode aired that the kiss wasn't
scripted, saying that it, quote, "just seemed
like something we should do."
Moira knows best
Many fans were left heartbroken when Oliver's
mother Moira bit the dust on The CW's Arrow.
Moira sacrificed her life for her children,
and moments before getting a sword through
the chest, she pleaded with her daughter to
look away ...
"Thea, I love you!
Close your eyes, baby!"
"No!"
Actress Susanna Thompson later revealed that
plea was actually improvised: she came up
with the "close your eyes" comment as a way
to bridge the gap between Moira telling Slade
to let her children live and her actual death.
Executive producer Marc Guggenheim ended up
loving the line, so it made the final cut.
Poppins improv
Happy Endings was a joke machine in its three
seasons on ABC.
With a naturally hilarious cast, it makes
sense some of those jokes would be improvised
— including a small but fun moment featuring
a Mary Poppins reference from Jane, played
by Eliza Coupe...
"Why is it so freezing in here?"
"I don't know, why don't you ask 'tuppence
a bag'?"
Coupe was referencing her husband, played
by Damon Wayans Jr., whose cologne attracts
pigeons.
The actress was surprised to see that people
on Twitter noticed and appreciated the relatively
obscure joke, which is a reference to the
"Feed the Birds" scene in the Disney classic.
"Feed the birds.
Tuppence a bag."
Off on the right foot
Arthur was never a great friend to Merlin
while starring on the character's namesake
BBC One series, but the two did have fun messing
with each other on the show — just as the
actors did behind the scenes.
According to actor Bradley James, the scene
in which his Arthur rubs his foot on Merlin's
face in season one after a sweet bonding conversation
was actually just him messing with actor Colin
Morgan, but it ended up making it into the
final cut.
James revealed on the DVD commentary that
that was his "favorite bit" of the episode,
but that he didn't do it in rehearsals.
Cry baby
There were a lot of heartbreaking moments
in Breaking Bad over the years, but one of
the biggest tearjerkers came when Walt's baby
daughter Holly started calling out for her
mother after her father abducted her.
"Won't that be nice, Holly?"
"Mama!
Mama.
Mama."
But that's not how the scene was planned.
During the bathroom scene, the little actress
saw her real mother just a few feet away,
and ended up calling out to her.
Credit goes to actor Bryan Cranston for rolling
with it, because the moment ended up being
an instant classic.
Fruit of his labor
Even if you only watched Psych intermittently,
you know how important pineapples were to
the show.
As it turns out, the whole thing started thanks
to an improvisation from Psych star James
Roday.
"Ooh!
Should I slice this up for the road?"
Roday was so enthusiastic about the joke that
the producers felt like he just had to keep
it in, and it spiraled out from there: One
of the tropical fruits appeared in almost
every episode of the series, in addition to
featuring prominently in its marketing over
the years.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!